cellular senescence is one of the nine
hallmarks of aging the prevalence seems
to increase of age and may even enhance
the aging process
but how much evidence is there to
support this
why do we need to identify senescent
cells and how can we identify senescent
cells
well hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where we will touch on all
of these questions as we discuss one of
my favorite topics cellulose in essence
especially because this article came out
recently that has developed a new
genetic tool to identify potentially a
different flavor of senescent cells so
is there clearance also beneficial well
you'll know the answer by the end of
this video
so where to begin
well a brief intro to cellulosin essence
of course
which is a term given to senescent cells
so what are senescent cells
well they are a term given to cells that
have entered the sulfate whereby they no
longer defied and acquired the ability
to produce a variety of factors that
they then secrete into their surrounding
environment
these secretive factors include factors
that can modulate the surrounding
environment of the cell and help fix any
damage that may have caused the cell to
become senescent in the first place
as well as inflammatory factors that may
recruit immune cells to clear the
senescent cells
so this all seems pretty positive
it's a mechanism to stop
messed up cells from further replicating
and potentially forming tumors and it
may even promote its removal from the
body
however if the senescent cells fail to
be cleared and continue secreting these
inflammatory factors
it is thought instead that it can have
deleterious pro-aging effects
and i found this nice figure from a
recent review the link is in the
description
which basically highlights a key
principle of senescent cells which is
they have a huge diversity
firstly a cell can become induced to s
for different reasons
maybe they have some dna damage maybe
there are too many reactive oxygen
species or they've replicated too many
times
secondly the cell types are different
you can have senecent skin cells or a
senescent liver cell and because they're
different cell types they will also
slightly differ
and then another region of heterogeneity
is in the factors that they secrete
that's not just the composition of what
exactly they secrete but also the
abundance how much of those factors they
secrete
and then there's different diseases that
the senescent cells have been linked to
so senescence has been linked with aging
and the clearance of senescent cells
seems to improve health in modern
organisms such as mice
in these landmark papers they showed
that when you remove the senescent cells
using a genetic inducible system
it alleviated some of the symptoms of
health the ones used so far have been
using an inducible system
which clears cells that have high
expression of a protein known as p16
and so you might be thinking why is she
talking about something called p16 now
well they were using high expression of
p16 as a marker for senescent cells
however i just told you that senescent
cells are very heterogeneous
is high p16 expression actually marking
all of the senescent cells or are just a
subset of these senescent cells getting
cleared and are these senescent cells
getting cleared the same ones as those
used by different synalytics drugs that
kill senescent cells so non-genetic
approaches
but this raises an interesting question
and an important question in the field
which is well how do we actually
identify senescent cells
well despite their diversity a key
shared feature across senescent cells is
that they have stopped the fighting
so-called cell cycle arrest
one protein involved in this cell cycle
arrest is p16 so the rationale with the
previous work was that cells with high
expression of p16 are likely to be
arrested and therefore also likely to be
senescent
however in essence there are two main
signaling pathways that are thought to
be involved in preventing the cells from
dividing
one involves p16 but the other involves
p21
so previous markers have often used p16
which actually has a very similar
function to p21 as they are both
involved in their cell cycle arrest
but they are regulated in different ways
p21 is famously regulated by the world's
coolest protein
that is p53
fun fact i submitted with my lab leader
musashi if you're in p53 and senescence
this week so i'll let you know if and
when it gets published but anyway p21 is
involved in the cell cycle arrest
feature of senescence
but compared to p16 as i just said
they're regulated in different ways
so the dependency on each of these
pathways also seems to vary depending on
the mode of induction and the cellular
context in terms of senescence so it's a
little bit complicated
but the important question is well why
p21 is it going to be a better reporter
of senescent cells than p16
as not all high p16 cells are senescent
and not all senescent cells have high
levels of p16
so can the same be said of p21 well
frankly it hasn't been widely explored
that is until now
as in this recent nature aging paper the
authors have developed a genetic mouse
model that basically uses the p21
promoter
to control the expression of the protein
crave recombinase
so if p21 is being expressed in that
cell the cells are now going to be
expressing this crave recombinase
if they can stabilize this protein by
feeding the mice with tamoxifen
it enables this protein to act on other
sites of dna and activate different
reporters
now it doesn't really matter if you
don't entirely understand what that
means but what you need to understand is
that it basically enables the
researchers to combine this senescence
reporter with other types of reporter
mice to further characterize these high
expressing p21 cells
so the first thing they were interested
in was trying to see where the senescent
cells accumulate
and so they combined their p21 mouse
model with a luciferase mouse such that
only luciferase is being expressed in
high p21 cells if the mice are treated
with tamoxifen and so luciferase acts as
a marker to be able to see where these
high p21 cells are
and so unsurprisingly they saw an
accumulation of p21 high cells with
increased dna damage
which makes sense as dna damage out of
his p53 which would also activate p21
but i also saw these p21 high cells in
myosphere the high fat diet and more
signal and older mice
comparing here three month old to 23
month olds
so it seems that p21 high cells appear
as you age from a high fat diet and from
increased dna damage
assuming that these p21 high cells are
indeed senescent cells
but to get a higher resolution vision of
the cells they then used a fluorescent
reporter
this time such that the p21 high cells
are red under the microscope
as you can hopefully see in these images
in the old mice that was around 1.5 to
10 of the red cells and you can see this
in visceral fat tissue brain intestine
heart liver and skeletal muscle tissue
so in previous research papers using
high p16 expression to detect senescent
cells they showed that clearance of
these senescent cells delayed aging
associated disorders
so the authors of this recent
publication were interested in saying
what would happen if you got rid of the
p21 high expressing cells
so to do this they crossed their mouse
reporter to a different reporter that
meant effectively that when the mice now
were given to multifen it killed any of
the cells that had high expression of
p21
and to see how effective the clearance
would be they performed intermittent
clearance which is in line with jim
kirkland's hit-and-run hypothesis which
is the idea that if you're going to
clear senescent cells because they take
some time to develop you may need to
only do it every so often
and so here they treated the old mice
with tamoxifen six times over the period
of three months and so remember that
this is going to be effectively killing
or removing these high p21 expressing
cells which they think are senescent
cells so as you can see here compared to
controls the mice seem to show
improvements in physical function after
the three-month treatment for example
they saw improvements in maximal walking
speeds grip strength hanging endurance
and also increases in the daily food
intake and daily activity
so the author suggested that this
demonstrated that the clearance of these
p21 high cells alleviated physical
frailty in old mice
so you may be underwhelmed or
overwhelmed with these results
or you might just be welled depending on
your interests but i think the study
provides an interesting insight into a
different subpopulation of senescent
cells as i've preached about before the
senescent state is heterogeneous and
that was most evident by the fact they
saw the accumulation of p21 high cells
in different locations to p16 high cells
moreover since p21 is regulated by p53
it suggests that these senescent cells
with high p21 may also have higher p53
activity so okay maybe that's more of
interest to myself
but it could definitely help to further
understand how p53 is involved in
aspects of senescence and or specific
tissues
but besides my biased interests in p53
this p21 high reporter mouse model
can be crossed with different genetic
mass models to further understand
regulators of the cenescent's associated
secretary phenotype
such that they could reduce the sasp
only in senescent cells rather than
current xenomorphics that would impact
not only tenescent cells but also the
normal cells so it will help to further
undepict exactly what these potential
drugs might be doing
and to take some final words from the
research paper itself
these mice can be indispensable models
for screening new senolytic drugs to
kill p21 high cells in vivo and greatly
accelerate next generation cenolitic
drug development and senescence
biomarker discovery
so it definitely will be a valuable and
powerful model for exploring senescence
and vivo which will be helpful for
potentially developing human
therapeutics
so with that i hope you've enjoyed
another senescence video favorites of
mine on this channel
um
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you